ich wette ihnen zu hause muss ich das
gar nicht sagen übermorgen ist
weltfrauentag es ist also die eine woche
im jahr wo unsere fast nur aus männern
bestehende redaktion den feministen in
sich entdeckt und raus lässt meine damen
und herren familienministerin franziska
giffey will ein gesetz durchbringen das
börsennotierte firmen in deutschland ab
einer bestimmten größe zwingen würde
mindestens eine frau im vorstand zu
haben denn deutsche vorstände sind immer
noch zu 92,3 prozent männlich 92 prozent
in aufsichtsräten sitzt ein bisschen
besser aus so wenn es kommt würde das
gesetz vom vgh allerdings auch nur für
rund 70 deutsche firmen gelten
es bleibt halten kampfes bleibt ein
kampf mit spannenden fragen auch für die
politik wie sie wollen eigentlich nur
männer cdu parteichefin werden keine
frauen
das habe ich mich auch schon oft gefragt
ja es ist ich habe es gesagt noch ein
weiter weg bis zur gleichberechtigung
und trotzdem muss der weltfrauentag
natürlich gefeiert werden
er muss gefeiert werden zb in berlin wir
sehen uns morgen kürzen dürfen
alexanderplatz denn der internationale
frauentag vista jetzt alle ist ein
frohes halten feierte berlin haben wir
uns verdient
doch da ist krumm wirst du sehen und
wenn die stellen bei dichter als lampe
oft erkennbar nicht gar nicht
ist nicht weit
doch in wort und knipst das licht aus
zur energiesparlampe doch auch im jahr
2020 bleibt der mann in praktisch allen
lebensbereichen das maß aller dinge und
das ist tatsächlich wörtlich zu nehmen
und herren für fast alles was bei uns
designt oder entwickelt wird ist der 1
meter 77 große mann mit 80 kilo die
referenz 80 kilo
deswegen sind handys oft zu klobig für
frauenhände sicherheitskleidung ist zu
groß und die raumtemperatur in büros zu
niedrig auch autos werden für größe und
gewicht von männern konzipiert die
wahrscheinlichkeit für frauen bei einem
autounfall schwer verletzt zu werden ist
47 prozent höher zu sterben 17 prozent
höher
ja tatsächlich werden bei crashtests
kaum frauen dummies eingesetzt ja der
mann als maß aller dinge gut streng
theologisch könnte man natürlich
argumentieren gott hat den mann nicht
umsonst zuerst erschaffen
wie die frau dann aus irgendwelchen
rippen resten zusammengelötet so steht
es in diesem alten buch ihr habt frauen
stellen die hälfte der weltbevölkerung
und sollen trotzdem für männer
konzipierte produkte kaufen war
ernsthaft was denn heute überhaupt noch
exklusiv für frauen designt die
verjüngung tonne in holland erfunden
sieht aus wie ein mittelalterliches
folterinstrument und erweist sich als
wahrhaft umwälzende erfindung kein mann
wird jemals mir sagen sie ist für mich
die verfügung ist sonne
ja es war ein uralter beitragen zdf
sendung von 2017 so bei uns laufen die
uhren anders
das phänomen gender data gap also
fehlende daten von frauen hat oft
absurde folgen sprachassistenten wie
siri und alex haben zwar wie sie wissen
frauenstimmen sind aber so programmiert
dass sie tiefe männerstimmen deutlich
besser verstehen
alexa noch das licht aus ich kann dich
nicht verstehen du hast so eine
unangenehm feminine stimme bitte mach
das licht ausmacht doch selber du
[ __ ] ohmann alexa mach endlich ist
scheußlich aus sehr gern manfred ich
liebe dich manfred
sie haben probleme
eine stimme zu verspielt
das ist ja noch kann man unter absurd
abbuchen aber besonders bitter ist es in
der medizin auch da basiert die
forschung nämlich fast nur auf männer
daten und das wird für patientinnen
regelrecht gefährlich professor
sebastian pufpaff leitet ein farmer
labor bei einem kleinen leverkusener
chemiekonzern der nicht namentlich
genannt werden möchte
herr pufpaff selbst bei tierversuchen
nehmen ihr überwiegend männliche tiere
warum eigentlich
nein wir nehmen ausschließlich männer
weil bei den weiblichen mäusen hast du
halt diese hormonschwankungen einmal im
monat diese zickigkeit die bisher
kriegen so schlechte laune
dann fressen die nur noch schokolade und
die männchen die fahne an vor langeweile
sich gegenseitig zu besteigen
kurz gesagt du kannst die ganzen daten
wegschmeißen es ist eine katastrophe
ja das ist tatsächlich ein gängiges
vorurteil frauen sein und ich zitiere
mit ihren fluktuierenden atypischen
hormonen und praktisch für die forschung
man müsste aber viel mehr unterschiede
erforschen beim herzinfarkt zb rund 70
prozent der männer klagen über den als
klassisch geltenden schmerz in der brust
der bis in den linken arm ausstrahlt
frauen zeigen andere symptome übelkeit
müdigkeit oder schlafstörungen dass er
bleiben ihre infekte oft unerkannt
gegenvorschlag können frauen bei ihrem
infarkt nicht einfach auch schmerzen im
linken arm kriegen den normaler mensch
[Gelächter]
ist das zu viel verlangt leute weil ich
mein so weit kommt das noch dass wir
jetzt für jedes einzelne produkt extra
frauen daten erheben denn hier dieser
proband zum beispiel testet gerade
freiwillig unser neues präparat gegen
menstruationsbeschwerden
und na noch regelschmerzen dankeschön
auf wiedersehen dann hilft es auch bei
frauen studie erfolgreich abgeschlossen
so und jetzt testet er noch unsere neue
anti cellulite creme schön einheiten die
orangenhaut viele medikamente wirken bei
frauen tatsächlich anders wegen der
enzyme und weil die wohl irgendwie
kleiner sind wurde mir gesagt nicht da
sind dann zum beispiel schlafmittel
dosen zu hoch und so was kann bei
anderen medikamenten richtig brenzlig
werden studien anderer institute haben
bereits gezeigt dass es herzmedikamente
gibt die das leben von frauen verkürzt
das von männern aber nicht mein gott ja
gut aber dafür haben frauen eine viel
höhere lebenserwartung
und wenn das jetzt so ein herzmedikament
ein bisschen ausgleicht mich stört
dieser ganze anklagende tun wenn ich
ehrlich bin ja weil man muss auch
feststellen wer waren denn die drei
größten genies aller zeiten
goethe einstein und leonardo dicaprio da
vinci der mit dem flugzeug nicht mehr
mit dem schiff
unter den unter den top 25 der
genialsten menschen aller zeiten ist nur
eine frau eine was marie curie was er
dir vun currywurst toll du auch
ansonsten soll die total verstrahlt
gewesen sein
wir männer machen fehler aber es heißt
ja trial and error
das heißt nichts weil and solutions also
wen haben wir denn die promillegrenze
fürs autofahren zu verdanken
ja mit sicherheit ein mann da saß ein
mann wahrscheinlich hacke dudelt dicht
in seinem auto im straßengraben und hat
dann bemerkt man jesus aber noch nicht
zu hause ja oder dank wem wissen wir
dass man im wohnzimmer nicht mit einem
holzkohlegrill grillen sollte das hat
einen man herausgefunden
und wer hat sich für das wissen geopfert
dass man seinen penis nicht in das wo
eines staubsaugers wirken sollte
das konnte nur ein man herausfinden
welche frau hätte das für uns
herausfinden können so ich weiß es heute
unpopulär das zu sagen aber vielleicht
ist der mann einfach schlauer
sorry ich hab die evolution ich erfunden
das war der liebe gott und der liebe
gott war auch ein mann
die sammelfrist du gerade die cellulite
creme
es gibt das her mensch also du bist echt
eine schande für unser geschlecht du
dödel professor sebastian pufpaff all
damen und herren
gibt nur eine institute in deutschland
an der charité in berlin für sie
schlechter spezifische unterschiede in
der medizin so zur wahrheit gehört aber
auch meine branche das fernsehen
bekleckert sich was das thema angeht
auch nicht gerade mit ruhm
eine aktuelle studie sagt die
hauptakteure im deutschen tv sind zu
zwei drittel männlich zu zwei dritteln
und je älter die frau desto seltener ist
sie auf dem bildschirm bei den über
50-jährigen kommen auf eine frau bei uns
acht männer und wie die schauspielerin
maria furtwängler beklagt betrifft das
wirklich alle genres
insbesondere ist ja schockierend dass
wir im kinderfernsehen schon ein solches
missverhältnis haben von einer von vier
rollen ist nur weiblich da hab ich in
ihrer studie gelesen sie zählen die die
die tiere und sagen die männer stimmen
überwiegen und die männlichen arbeiten
überwiegend wollen sie jetzt benjamin
blümchen gender mainstreaming ja ganz
genau klaus maria furtwängler will
benjamin blümchen den rüssel abschneiden
du bist einer großen sache auf der spur
kleber soviel zum thema alte weiße
männer erzählform weltfrauentag das geht
auch anders die ihr suchtpotenzial meine
damen und herren
[Applaus]
gender pay gap die ungleiche bezahlungen
zwischen männern und frauen das ist ja
immer noch ein problem der untergrund
tierisch aufgeregt uns total auf weil es
zu unseren ungunsten ist andersrum wäre
okay gewesen
und dazu haben wir ein kleines
protestlied mitgebracht
man sagt wir frauen seiner sanfte
geschlecht so zart so weit so lief so
wunderschön
wir sahen duft und eleganz und stets
gepflegt und dabei auch noch sehr hübsch
doch hör auf mich mein kind war das
alles nur lügen
[Musik]
wer denn genauso scheiße wir bestreiten
auch low und verträgen viel bier
wir sind genauso scheiße
ich mich nicht hier werden genauso
scheiße wir
döbeln wir hauen wir sagen wir können
auch an randalieren und deshalb wollen
wir auch genau so viel cola faltig
[Musik]
frauen haben auch einen
verdauungsapparat frauen packen täglich
ungehemmt und wenn sie sich bewegen
gegen schwitzen sie ganz ungeniert
frauen vögeln rum und gel fremdmittel
nicht so blind weil wir auf eure
diese
[Musik]
der sind genauso scheiße hier
ich trete ganz stark von die fresse für
vier werden genau so wie ein stier
wir sind genauso scheiße
[Musik]
weil sie mich aufregt dass sie männer in
der comedy ist es so macht eine
verträumte überlegt doch mal mario barth
dieter nuhr oliver welke und julia julia
uhr jetzt macht mal halblang
du kannst uns auch nicht direkt
vergleichen mit doktor eckart von
hirschhausen so ein bisschen eine andere
liga verstehst du sorry das jetzt übers
ziel hinaus geschaut hast kann es nicht
machen du hast natürlich recht wird
nämlich zu zweit
[Musik]
[Applaus]
wir sind genauso scheiße hier richtig an
mein freund wäre dies passt zu mir
[Musik]
so wie ein tier wir sind genauso scheiße
wir laufen wird
also kohle
bis morgen hier noch
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin's der heute-show
ersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liegt - wollt dann abonniert jetzt
den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal der stelle
[Musik]